vertical snakes I'm of the opinion that
they should be one of the first body
tracers that pois Spinners learn how to
do but once you've learned them how do
you flow with them how do you transition
in and out of other moves with them well
that is the point of this
video Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and in this video I'm
going to be showing you some of my
favorite transitions that make use of
vertical snakes but before we dive in I
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk flow fests flow toys pyro Tera
light toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
amazing companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non- bus
friend of the channel Becca Beck
thank you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission so if you
are a subscriber to my channel it is
very likely that you have already seen
the tutorial that I posted on Monday
about how to do those vertical snakes
and if you haven't I will go ahead and
include a link to that tutorial down in
the description as well as up in the
cards now if you got it down more than
likely you're trying to figure out what
to do with it next and that's where I
come in see I've had a few years of
playing around with these clearly and I
have a lot of ideas that that I think
are fun and I hope that you're going to
think they're fun too so I'm basically
going to break this down I'm going to
give you beginner intermediate and
advanced transitions that make use of
vertical snakes and within each of those
different categories I'm going to give
you two possibilities so let's start off
with the beginner stuff now if you
watched my tutorial you'll know that the
way I like to teach this is actually to
have people start with their hip and
their shoulder reels and just practice
going back and forth between them as
they perform these snakes and the good
news is that means that you've got a
couple automatic transitions that are
built in there namely whenever you're
performing these snakes here you can
always pause on one level be it your
hips or perhaps instead you'd like to
pause at your shoulders and when you do
so you can just switch back into those
same reels you might want to alternate
this up say stopping with the shoulder
reels one time around and then stopping
with the hip reels another time around
or maybe you want to work your way up
slowly thinking hip reel
shoulder reels and then boom we have the
fullon move after that all of these are
excellent possibilities and of course we
also have the option of using that
section where the PO are coming back
down to each side of us right here to
switch into something like say giant
extensions in an outward or reverse
butterfly or perhaps we could use that
as a moment to come together into a
smaller reverse butterfly both options
are great and of course in both cases
the the work really is just removing
those pedals and or reels from your
hands as you're coming up your Center
Line and just let your arm sweep out and
around instead of pausing easy peasy all
right so with the beginner stuff out of
the way let's talk about some
intermediate level transitions so the
first transition I'm going to show you
here involves taking that moment where
your arms are moving up your center
right here and turning it into a POI
Crosser like so how exactly does this uh
sorcery work well I will show you
essentially what we're looking at here
is the left hand as it's coming up we do
a beat over our shoulder and then come
out and around we do a beat over our
shoulder and then come out and around
right before we do that however we have
a little moment where the poy is
sticking out to our left hand side where
we can stop it for a second and drop it
into a pendulum like so when this
happens we can do a direction change and
switch from the left hand POI spin
counterclockwise relative to us to it
spinning clockwise and when that happens
check it out I can then sneak my right
hand underneath it and now both of the
PO are spinning in the same direction
but in Split time taada to get back all
we got to do is perform another pendulum
with that left hand and that leaves us
back in the exact same position that we
were in when we transitioned into it so
we transition in like so and then back
out like so it's just a matter of making
sure that you get that right hand po
tucked back under your armpit and then
back out and around okay but real talk I
actually think that my favorite
transition of all time to do with
vertical snakes is this one taking them
into a horizontal plane with either a
4be cork screw or just a standard cork
screw it doesn't actually really matter
and then bringing them right back out
goodness how are we going to pull that
one off so the key here is to remember
that as we're going up the sides of our
body there's a brief moment here where
both of the PO are sticking out to the
sides it happens when my right hand POI
is tucked underneath my armpit and my
left hand poy is about to go back behind
my shoulder and when that happens I'm in
a perfect spot to do what I like to
refer to as a plain snap that is I can
simply pull the poy from one plane to
another boom and get them moving around
in a horizontal plane like so and to get
back out all I got to do is bring them
to a stop out at the sides and then drop
them back into that vertical snake just
like that all right intermediate has
been a lot of fun but it is time to
finally dive into those advanced moves
all right so next up we have the one and
only move on this list that involves
throws namely we're going to do some
pretty quick little anti-spin throws to
swap the poy back and forth between our
hands like so the idea here is that
you're essentially
popping the PO up and doing uh almost
like an ins spin throw in Reverse here
where I want to pop the poy head up Let
the handle slide underneath it and catch
it in the other hand on the other side
so as we go around here boom like so
boom like so and you notice as I'm doing
this I'm also letting the PO kind of do
a little pendulum at the end of the
throw and kind of uh going back out to
the sides and then just dropping the PO
right back into my vertical snake like
so all right so I've got one last
transition to show you but before I do I
have a quick favor to ask see if you
come this far I am pretty sure that you
have an interest in po Trix and flow
maybe even broader in the world of flow
Arts which is awesome because I make
tons of videos on those topics so if
you'd like to check out all of my videos
as soon as they drop the best way to do
that is to subscribe to the channel and
ring the bell helps you out helps me out
helps everybody out thanks all right so
this next one to me almost feels like a
slight of hand trick namely I'm going to
take advantage of that moment where my
hands are almost together in the middle
and use it to switch into a meteor
orientation that is twoo one hand where
I can spin both of the POI in just that
one hand here's how this works so the
first thing to realize is that I'm
actually Shifting the grip in my
dominant hand uh as I'm getting into
this transition I'm going from uh using
the standard key grip at my thumb in to
shifting it over to a pinky based grip
uh over here between my pinky and ring
fingers the reason I'm doing this is
when my hands come together that's a
moment when I'm going to take my left
hand and transition the uh handle of my
left hand POI over to the thumb end of
my right hand now as I go around here
watch for
it I do have this moment where the two
poy are pointed away from each other and
from here I can do one of two things all
right so here's one option I can take my
vertical snakes around switch my grip ha
wouldn't have even known if I hadn't
told you would you so as I come around
here I can take advantage of that moment
when the poer out to either side do a
grip transfer and switch to split Time
same direction maybe take it around in a
meteor flower like so or do a spiral
wrap all these are great options option
number two is that we keep the POI in a
butterfly orientation and after I do my
grip switch and we bring the hands close
to each other boom I can switch into a
one-handed butterfly maybe even if I
want to get fancy I can go up to a
one-handed Mercedes instead totally up
to you but the good news is that also
means that we can go straight back into
that vertical snake because our po are
already there pretty nifty huh want to
see how far you can take your flow with
those vertical snakes come join me for
body tracing Bonanza body tracers are
the focus of my new live stream po dance
class over the course of 4 weeks I'll
teach you not just vertical snakes and
three other amazing poy tricks but also
how to transition back and forth between
them and how to perform a beautiful
piece of Po choreography that integrates
each and every one of these tricks into
an amazing performance that you can do
for your family and friends registration
is open now all lessons are recorded so
you can watch them and rewatch them at
your leisure head on over to crowdcast
doio drexfactor PO to register sweet so
youall have a lot of options out there
to play with go ahead and uh if you
would record some video of yourself
playing with them and uh go ahead and
tag me in that video on whatever
platform on social media is your
platform of choice I'd love to see your
hard work and leave you a little bit of
encouragement did you get anything out
of this video please make sure to like
share comment and subscribe to help
other people find the video and to help
my channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now y'all rock thank you
all so much and if those of you out
there watching are not currently
supporters but you'd like to become
supporters you can do that by signing up
for my patreon over at
you'll be helping me out in my mission
to bring po spinning and flow Arts to
the whole wide world go check that out
please and thank you and if you'd like
to check out that tutorial I did on how
to learn vertical snakes in only 30
minutes I will include a link to it down
in the description of this video as well
as up on screen thanks so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
yourselves today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon take care now peace